i always like to look at the
link between things cause and effect the
association between things
the relationship between
common problems and medications
and their side effects and i think the
best topic to demonstrate this is with
the cardiovascular system so you have
various problems with your heart okay
you have arrhythmias
you have
high cholesterol even though from my
viewpoint that's not a problem unless
you're doing high carbs but when you're
dealing with things like atherosclerotic
plaquing you have a combination of
fibrin which is the protein you have
cholesterol and you have calcium and
then you have clots okay a thrombus
and there's various medications to thin
the blood to reduce your chance of
clotting and then you have like
tachycardia which is high pulse rate
and another condition called
hypertension which is high blood
pressure and each separate problem comes
with its own medication its own
treatment and of course each medication
has its own side effects but with
cardiovascular conditions they don't
really go very deep as far as causation
they might say that heart disease is
caused by high blood pressure or they
might say that heart disease is caused
by a clot
or a buildup of cholesterol or heart
disease is caused by arrhythmias they're
not going deeper they might mention
lifestyle
diet
too much salt eating fatty foods but
that's about it what i want to talk
about is
electrolytes in relationship to the
cardiovascular system so we have
electrolytes which are
like potassium magnesium
calcium and sodium and these
electrolytes really control the nerves
and the muscles and the relationships
and the heart is a muscle and it has
nerves that control it
and it has even a pacemaker that
controls the rhythm and what you're
going to find very shortly there's this
huge connection between
electrolyte
imbalances
and cardiovascular
function and what i mean by electrolyte
imbalances you should never just rely on
one electrolyte or take it for a long
period of time you can take it for a
short period of time
to correct an imbalance but you have to
realize these electrolytes
work in a balance
in other words if you have too much
potassium for example you're going to
have a deficiency of magnesium and a
deficiency potassium could also be
related to a deficiency in magnesium and
so some of these electrolytes have a
direct and indirect effect on each other
you also have the relationship between
calcium and magnesium if one goes up the
other one might go down
you have another relationship between
potassium and sodium if you're consuming
a lot of salt for example
you're going to need more potassium and
if you have enough potassium you'll be
protected by a lot of sodium and then
there's even a relationship between
calcium and sodium calcium can even
block sodium as in a calcium channel
blocker which is a medication
for arrhythmias and blood pressure and
so some of these uh medications for
heart conditions
actually either block or increase an
electrolyte so before i get into the
relationships i want to just first talk
about arrhythmias okay this is a
abnormal heart rhythm the heart should
normally be in rhythm and when it's not
in rhythm you can have a lot of issues
with pulling blood and clotting and
all sorts of issues but what you need to
know
is that
you really need all of the electrolytes
in the right balances for everything to
work because you can have an arrhythmia
problem with a deficiency of potassium
as well as an excess of potassium you
can have arrhythmias if there's not
enough magnesium or if there's too much
magnesium
you can have arrhythmias if you have not
enough calcium or too much calcium and
so the key is the sweet spot so if i
were to tell you
too much calcium causes heart attacks
for example and i just did a video on
that of course you're going to be
avoiding calcium but what you have to
realize is that you also have the
problem with deficiencies so you need
the balance of all the electrolytes and
of course the cool thing about getting
your electrolytes from food primarily is
that you get these electrolytes in the
correct balance and if you're going to
take electrolyte powder of course make
sure it's in the right balance so the
next thing i want to tell you is the
relationship between potassium and
magnesium i already mentioned that too
much potassium can create a magnesium
deficiency now you might be saying well
how am i going to get too much potassium
is it just from consuming too much
potassium
actually probably not it's going to be
more from the soil
most farming
methods now are focused on just three
minerals okay
npk
n
nitrogen
p phosphorus and k is potassium
so if you're going to just use mpk in
the soils and you're going to put a lot
in there
you're going to create a magnesium
deficiency
and magnesium has an anti-thrombotic
effect in other words it helps to reduce
thrombosis or clotting magnesium is
incredible for the heart it's good for
arrhythmias it is a natural calcium
channel blocker which is another
medication they use
for
high blood pressure and arrhythmias and
so unfortunately a lot of our food that
we consume
is very very deficient in magnesium
because the soils are deficient in
magnesium
and the plants even though they have
chlorophyll that green stuff which is
made out of magnesium is usually low in
magnesium and i do want to say also if
you're low in potassium that can create
a magnesium deficiency so again we just
need the right amounts of each but since
i'm going to be starting a channel on
growing food in
plants i'm going to be talking a lot
about this npk and how it just throws
off the balance of all these other
minerals that are needed so there's some
fascinating data in
having enough magnesium in preventing
clots there's other great data on having
enough magnesium and preventing
arrhythmias or palpitations i mean it
just blows me away that some
cardiologists
they put you on a medication to regulate
the heart beat but they're not looking
at the electrolytes and please don't
come off your medication from this video
check with your doctor before making any
changes the reason i'm doing this video
is to educate you so you can then
educate your doctor or at least bring up
questions that need to be brought up and
then we have this uh this other symptom
of high blood pressure which has been
hugely significantly associated with a
potassium deficiency with a magnesium
deficiency i mean even the fda recently
came out and
are allowing
people to use the magnesium claim for
helping decrease the risk of high blood
pressure of course it has to be phrased
in a certain way so high blood pressure
can come from low potassium low
magnesium and
high
calcium okay
we'll come back to that and this is why
a common medication that's used for high
blood pressure is calcium
channel
blockers what does a calcium channel
blocker do it blocks
calcium to help you lower
blood pressure it also helps with atrial
fibrillation because too much of one
electrolyte can throw off other
electrolytes
now what's interesting as a side effect
from calcium channel blockers
i think if i'm not mistaken it's 70
percent of people that take this are at
risk for a side effect of edema because
your lymphatic system is dependent on
your vascular system and if you're going
to inhibit calcium you can many times
inhibit the muscular contraction that is
supposed to help push this fluid and you
can end up with edema in your lower legs
as a side effect from the calcium
channel blockers and of course another
side effect from the calcium channel
blockers is low
calcium now remember when i said low
calcium can be a cause of
heart arrhythmias and then we get
another group of medications that
are diuretics
that are used to help lower blood
pressure
i mean this just blows me away like
there's a
diuretic called hctz
that has direct side effects of a
potassium deficiency a magnesium
deficiency a sodium deficiency and not a
deficiency but an excess of calcium in
other words it causes you to retain
calcium now remember when i just
mentioned high blood pressure and that
can be caused by
not enough potassium not of magnesium
and too much calcium so diuretics could
actually create high blood pressure
indirectly and two other side effects
are very very surprising from these
diuretics one is it can increase your
risk for diabetes because it can
increase your blood sugars and two it
can increase your lipids as in cause
high cholesterol but don't worry we have
statins for that but of course the
statins have a side effect of increasing
blood pressure as well as increasing
blood sugars
as well
so anytime you have the treatment for
something causing part of the same
problem to me you don't have the optimum
solution a solution shouldn't give you
additional problems
and then we have um
things that thin the blood like
uh warfarin so warfarin blocks vitamin
k1 but it has a very
severe and significant side effect of
causing vascular calcification
so that can definitely increase blood
pressure now there's also something
called a beta blocker and that has to do
with reducing adrenaline okay part of
the sympathetic nervous system to help
reduce blood pressure but there's two
interesting side effects one is that it
can cause a potassium deficiency okay
and two it can cause a magnesium
deficiency now both magnesium and
potassium deficiencies
can increase cortisol and adrenaline
i mean potassium and magnesium are the
physiological tranquilizers they relax
you they decrease stress they help you
sleep and so the medication to help you
lower blood pressure can actually end up
causing more adrenaline or cortisol this
just doesn't make sense to me and then
we get to another medication called an
ace inhibitor and this has to do with um
affecting certain hormones that
can affect blood
fluids in your body retention of fluids
as well as blood pressure so an ace
inhibitor targets more blood pressure
issues but the problem is
the side effect from that is the
retention of potassium and the depletion
of magnesium so again these
solutions for cardiovascular problems
really throw off your electrolytes in in
direct and indirect ways so in summary a
very very important thing to know about
a healthy cardiovascular system is the
balance
of the electrolytes in their right
ratios and you need to look at the big
picture you need to ask questions that
dig deep into the underlying root causes
in certain parts of heart disease and
the big takeaway is that
any solution that gives you a bigger
problem is not the optimum solution so
if you want to know the best foods to
support a healthy cardiovascular system
i put that video up right here check it
out
you